CATHERINE DRENNAN: We started
using these clicker devices
in 511.1, and clickers are there
small credit card sized devices
where I can put a
question up on my computer
that the students will see,
and it will have three, four,
or five choices.
And the students can
look at the question
and click in what they
think the answer is.
And this was a big
trend, I think,
in education for big
classrooms because it allows
the students to engage more.
The teacher, who's standing in
the front of the room with 300
people, they're not necessarily
going to raise their hand
and go, I'm confused,
because it's a big class.
But if I ask them a question
to see if they're confused,
they'll click in.
I'll go, oh yeah, that did
not go the way I wanted.
Clearly people are confused.
Let's talk about this some more.
Or 95% get it right,
and it's like, OK,
I can move on and go
on to the next thing.
So it's a great, I
think, teaching tool.
Everyone should be clicking
in to the clicker question.
So does someone want to explain
why this is the correct answer?
But when we first
brought them in,
the students were not
so excited by them.
And there were other classes
at MIT that were using them,
but it was like,
OK, we'll do this.
But I didn't get that there was
a lot of enthusiasm for them.
So I tried to think about ways
that we could make it more fun.
And so one thing that
I thought is that we
could have some competition.
And in 511.1, there are
multiple recitations
that are run by a
graduate student TA,
so everyone in the class
would have their recitation
group of 20 people.
And so I thought, well,
on Friday in class,
we'll have a little
competition and we'll
see which recitation gets the
most clicker questions right.
And they will get
a reward, which
is maybe some donuts at
recitation next week.
Something small.
Some kind of food.
And largely, it was
bragging rights.
Our recitation got the
most questions right.
So we started doing
this, and then I
surveyed the students
both before we
had done the competitions
and after to kind of look
at whether the students
liked the competitions
and felt like they
were learning.
And I found a really
big difference.
So students had
always said, yes, I
try to answer the
questions correctly.
But then when we asked them
questions about how hard they
wanted to work to understand
chemistry and their real desire
to learn and the
impact of the course,
that with the competitions,
all of these things
were much higher.
And so it just seemed like
they were more engaged.
There was more of a
buy in, and I would
talk to some of these students.
And they were like, oh yeah,
I'm in Jay's recitation.
And they felt a
part of something.
They had ownership.
And a lot of the groups
in the recitation,
they would start
studying together.
Even though they didn't
know each other before
and this is often
freshman year, so these
might be some of
the first people
they're meeting
in their classes.
They got very serious
about the competition
some years, so they would
meet the night before class
to review some things so they
were ready for the competition.
And I've seen
students who've been
doing this for a number of
years in their junior year,
and they're like, oh yeah, I
get together with my friends
from the clicker competition
every month or so.
We go have dinner
or do something fun.
So they're making
friends for life.
And so I think that this is
just in a big 300 person class,
feeling like you belong,
you're an active participant
rather than a passive one.
These clicker competitions
built this sense of team.